die niederländer haben mit am meisten
mit den folgen des klimawandels zu
kämpfen der steigende meeresspiegel
macht dem land zu schaffen
es droht im wahrsten sinne des wortes
runterzugehen architekten haben eine
idee wie das verhindert werden kann
mit schwimmenden häusern wie die zukunft
auf dem wasser aussieht jetzt im pixum
science fiction
hamburg ist eine der spezielleren
stadtteile amsterdams auf dem größten
binnensee des landes liegt der stadtteil
und zugleich auch das wasser boning im
projekt der name verrät es ja schon auf
dem wasser wohnen mehr als 50 häuser
villen und jetzt kommt's mehrstöckige
mietshäuser schwimmen dort auf dem
wasser das unternehmen bot us studio nl
wirkte bei dem innovativen bauformen mit
können alltours vom water studie äußerte
sich zu dem projekt wir wollten zeigen
dass man nicht nur hausboote bauen kann
sondern richtige häuser die schon
erreicht wurde das mit extra
konzipierten fundamenten bestehen aus
mit spezialbeton ummantelten styropor
diese könnten frei aneinander gebaut
werden und würden bis zu einer
seitenlänge von 200 metern einen
stabilen untergrund bilden wäre nicht
2013 die finanzkrise ausgebrochen
könnten wir wo vermutlich schon heute
die resultate des new yorker projects
bewundern
ziel des new yorker projekts waren 600
wohnhäuser 600 schwimmende wohnhäuser
geplant war dieses projekt für den süden
den haag dort werden bis heute große
flächen mit enormem aufwand vor den
wassermassen geschützt pumpen sorgen tag
und nacht dafür dass das wasser nicht in
den stadtteil eindringt die geldmengen
die europäische länder wie die
niederländer aufbringen können stehen in
ärmeren ländern nicht zur verfügung
viele dieser armen und durch den
meeresspiegel bedrohten länder bräuchten
aber genau diese technologie den
vereinten nationen zufolge leben rund 40
prozent der menschen in wassernähe doch
wie schon gesagt nicht alle haben das
nötige kleingeld um sich wortwörtlich
über wasser zu halten ein haus in aid
kostet teilweise bis zu 500.000 euro
wer soll das bezahlen
die niederländische bevölkerung kämpft
seit jahren mit den drohnen wassermassen
der nordsee mehr als 30 prozent der
landfläche liegen unter bzw auf höhe des
meeresspiegels dementsprechend oft kommt
es zu überschwemmungen oder anderen
schwierigkeiten mit den riesigen
wassermassen um sich vor der nordsee zu
schützen haben die niederländer eine
3000 kilometer langen mauer aufgebaut
3000 kilometer bestückt mit deichen
dämmen und flut wären das imposanteste
flut wer ist das land bestehend aus zwei
toren liegt es mehr als 7000 tonnen zu
vergleich das fundament der allianz
arena in münchen liegt nur 180 tonnen
das wären dann ein bisschen mehr als 38
fundamente der münchner arena all diese
bauten würden aber eben bald nicht mehr
ausreichen um das land vor diesen
riesigen wassermassen zu schützen
experten zufolge wird der meeresspiegel
in den nächsten 85 jahren mehr als einen
meter ansteigen immer höhere und
breitere deichbauten helfen da nicht so
klimaforscher partner karat von der
universität bergen zügen in den
niederlanden eine der renommiertesten
universitäten im bereich wasser
stadtplanungen die tu delft und wieder
andere universitäten arbeiten unter
hochdruck daran lösungen zu finden die
so genannte älter kommission kostet die
niederlande und 12 milliarden euro im
jahr
dieses geld wird eingesetzt um den
wissenschaftlichen fortschritt in die
tat umzusetzen
vor zehn jahren gab das ministerium für
städte plant und wo ganze 15 gebiete
frei um den forschern platz für die
praxis zu schaffen in diesen gebieten
dürfen die experten ihre projekte testen
und verwirklichen wie beispielsweise in
zwei milliarden euro könnten sich schon
bald auch außerhalb den niederlanden
auszahlen
die philippinen sind stark sehr stark
betonen von den sie umgebenden
wassermassen in der prüfung zehn
millionen für die kinos wurden bleibt
der climate change kongress philipp 1
organisationen die folgen des
klimawandels also überschwemmung zu
spüren bekommen nun kommen die 1,2
milliarden euro investitionen ins spiel
experten aus den niederlanden reisen an
bord um den menschen zu helfen mit ihren
erfolgten kenntnissen wollen sie den
jährlichen schaden durch die
wassermassen deutlich reduzieren 146
millionen euro pro jahr für jahr
ausgegeben um die flut schäden zu
beheben
das projekt steht noch ganz am anfang
aber es bietet dem entwaffnung einen
funken hoffnung
eine weitere alternative unseren rahmen
zu verleihen wäre über den wolken zu
leben wie genau das funktionieren soll
erfahrt ihr im video und web und zum
blog ist hier unten und würdet ihr in
einen geschwungenen ausleben können
oder habt ihr vielleicht leichte
maschine urlaub schon auf einem hausboot
bewohnt lasst es uns in den kommentaren
wissen diskutiert ab dass leistungen der
zukunft ist ansonsten bis dann bleibt